all right and then we've got the supply
shock ratios and i saw you tweet this
last night and i literally just got a
smirk on my face and i said will has
been all over this chart and this is
like the money chart so explain to
everyone again what is the supply shock
ratios and what is the chart
showing right yeah i mean this is
probably like if i had to you know use
one chart or
i would all also use the liquid supply
shock ratio but this one from a macro
sense is just
you know it really speaks for itself
because you're taking a ratio of all the
supply held by long-term holders to
short-term holders and you're running
you know you're taking a comparison of
those um and so whenever the long-term
guys lock up a poor a certain portion of
supply you start to get this supply
shock or supply squeeze effect in the
market and then one thing one thing
that's important to note is well first
of all we're at an all-time high in this
like by far if you look in the top right
but also in the you know over the next
probably month or so
i mean this isn't for sure but i would
suspect you'll start to see them uh trim
their holdings and we'll keep an eye on
this for sure but
you know in inter strength you see the
long-term guys start to sell like they
don't perfectly time the top but they
slowly sell into strength and then they
accumulate into weakness um and so as we
start to move higher and you know with
with you know major other major uh you
know bull rallies that that bitcoins had
you just naturally are going to see
those long-term guys start to distribute
their coins so don't take that as an
absolute red flag um
because i think now at this point that
you know they've locked up this large
portion of supply and this what seems
like what happens uh every time the
ratio gets in the top you know part of
the
the little green uh highlighted zone i
put there you know they lock up a
certain amount of supply you know as the
marginal demand keeps stepping in the
only way they're able to acquire new
coins is to start dating the price up
because the float is so low and then
once that starts to build up the
momentum it's already kind of taken a
leg of its own and then the long-term
guys can start to sell into that into
that rally but i think we've now kind of
initiated that demand obviously um you
know the confirmation will be like above
all-time highs to say that that's
absolutely you know the case but
um yeah i think like at this point we're
getting ready to you know have an
exciting remainder of the quarter as
we've been talking about you know since
summer so it's been really cool i
remember we first started following this
the ratio was below the green box and
we've just been on this for for weeks
now so
uh yeah i mean this is from a macro
sense this is probably the the you know
most bullish chart i guess you could say
so what's really interesting about this
is in prior
uh bull markets if we pulled the chart
up one more time what you can see is
that it kind of tops out in the green
zone right so if you go all the way back
to i think it's uh 2015 in uh 18 or 17
into 18 and then in uh 2020 you can just
see that it kind of ends up running up
into the green zone and then coming back
down
this is way higher than it's been
previously do you think that that
indicates
as the price increases it will be more
volatile it'll be kind of like an even
more breathtaking move or should we not
read into almost like the severity of
how much further uh we've gone past that
green zone than in prior uh bull markets
yeah i think
that stands out to me and then also the
base of which um at the bottom of you
know well at the bottom of the ratio but
at the you know that distribution zone
from earlier this year around 50 60 k um
you'll see that that
the base that the long-term holders had
to build off of was much higher than
that of of you know at the end of 2017
so yeah i think it just kind of goes to
show you this behavioral shift in the
market um also like
if you if you plot out the liquid supply
shock ratio and over time i think this
one makes makes the point i'm gonna make
like really uh clear is it over time
it's in this descending channel in the
first half of bitcoins is because
existence it spent that in in the bottom
half of the channel in kind of the
latter half in the upper part and then
after covet of last year which i don't
think is a coincidence you started to
see it break out above that channel and
it's now kind of floating in in no man's
land where we've never really seen it
before um and so yeah i think you know
you're seeing this behavioral shift in
the market of people or just holding
their bitcoin for the long term um and
and i think this is you know pairing
pairing the two of these charts together
i think i think you could reasonably
make that argument